[Applause]
so basically
what i read about it is there's an
author tanahisi coates
who is a black activist and has written
a lot about like uh
you know black success and activism in
the united states
and he's very left-wing yeah very
left-wing and he was brought in by
marvel to write uh or i guess like
consult on the new
captain america i i'm not actually
positive which uh which convict it is
red skulls usually developing
captain america yeah so he's writing for
that and basically
i just saw excerpts from the comics but
basically red skull's character
is based off of jordan peterson the
philosophy
of the character right so basically like
red school's whole thing is he's like
okay i'm going to come in i'm going to
give men that are lost a purpose i'm
going to tell them that
uh you know they're going to fight for
themselves and they're going to fight
for their culture and their people and
blah blah blah they're
you know left wanting more and they're
hopeless and they're worthless and blah
blah blah and i can get them to do
anything
and i make them believe in them
ultimately they'll fight for me and
whatever else right he's basically
red school is radicalizing men to fight
for his evil cause and then the ways
he's doing it that are similar to
peterson
are like right and so like they'll have
little excerpts from the comics i can
even pull them up but
one was uh ten rules for life jordan
pierce has 12 rules yeah so like there's
very direct like uh
sort of like yeah clean your room yeah
there's things like that like make your
bed
and like cultural marxism or buzzwords
that are put in there yeah and uh
jordan peterson responded to it being
like yo this is absurd
and then he's kind of leaned into the
humor of it like online people started
taking actual jordan peterson quotes and
then putting them on
red skull and it's like make your bed
yeah
like this super villain yeah it's like
nazi super villain you should make your
bed in the morning
responsibility for your life yeah take
care of your family
don't lie like things that he actually i
guess believes in
but it does bring up an interesting
discussion and we were having this talk
like when we were traveling to raleigh
which is like he i guess tony you see
coach is implying that jordan peterson's
rhetoric leads to
like white extremism or alt-right
behavior is that fair to say
yeah like i guess his argument would be
that jordan peterson funnels people into
all right nazism right so
which jordan peterson is vehemently
against not nazism like right i mean his
whole research is based around how do we
not create
a hitler type right that's why he's
against censoring of speech because he
believes that those hitler types censor
he's like freedom of ideas is what stops
the hitler thing this is not me cap him
for peterson i'm just trying to say this
is
at least my understanding of peterson so
what is interesting is the discussion i
think is how much
responsibility do you have for your
followers
let's say jordan peterson getting people
who maybe felt
like they weren't allowed to love
themselves or weren't allowed to have
pride or maybe they were like
these white kids that were like
listening to a lot of leftist philosophy
which is like hey white person you're
racist no matter what
yeah you're sexist no matter what and
they felt a lot of insecurity based on
that
and then jordan peterson goes no you're
not a bad person like this leftist stuff
about you just being born racist is
wrong yeah like you're a good guy
maybe a certain percentage of them take
that and go a little bit more extreme
and they start going a little bit
alt-right yeah
jordan peterson is not saying the
alt-right stuff but if he is
the gateway drug what responsibility
does he have again i don't believe he is
but if that is the argument
of tonight coach is he at all
responsible for what people who follow
his stuff do
yeah it's tough because it's i think
it's more nuanced than that you're not
responsible for
everybody you can't be but there is some
responsibility and i don't know i don't
listen to a lot of jordan peterson but
if he keeps saying like yo guys we
cannot walk down the path of supremacy
racial supremacy in any direction white
supremacy's bad whatever
then he's doing what he can do that's
really all you can do is keep saying
within your message
like all right guys let's try to keep
this [ __ ] focused on what i'm saying
and not take it further and the guys
that go off the reservation
have at that point stop listening to you
because they're not listening to your
message
and once they start breaking your
message they're no longer responsible
follower anymore i can't i can't bring
them back they found some new drug for
them
some new place that fills the void where
what i'm trying to teach and this is
going off what we're saying here what
i'm trying to teach is you have
self-worth
once you have self-worth you generally
stop seeking a bunch of new [ __ ]
real self-worth you're trying to you're
filling the void yourself so you don't
need somebody else to fill it if that
void didn't get filled from what i
taught you it helped a little bit and it
covered it up like a band-aid then when
the band-aid is ripped off
all right i need my new thing what's
kind of like this but a little bit
more dopamine or whatever stronger hit
now it's just a little bit more extreme
thing then a little more extreme thing
and i can't be responsible for that
my [ __ ] didn't help you that's not my
fault but i'm not responsible for you
that's what i'm from and again i haven't
read yeah he'd be having a lot of rules
this guy so i don't know
but you can't be responsible for it
literally distilled it down to just 12.
that's a lot but you got more rules than
jesus dawg and you got more rules than
jesus
yeah chill you just got down
who the [ __ ] is you they have more rules
than jesus
son what do you think mark that's the
thing like i
like i'll listen to jordan peterson like
i don't i never thought that anything
you said was like
super radical like obviously there was
controversy in what he said yeah
i recognize the controversy and i
disagree with him on certain points yeah
like
he'll talk about like you know leftist
cultural marxism and stuff and how the
left is blah blah and i'm like
yeah i feel like you're kind of
mischaracterizing what like the left is
trying to do
but ultimately like i understand where
he's coming from and i agree with his
points on like uh
academic level but at the same time like
i don't know like
he it might be reasonable to compare him
to like weed
you know i mean like that people that do
hard drugs will start with weed
but but a lot of people that do hard a
lot of people that do weed don't end up
doing hard drugs
right and like there's nothing wrong
with weed right there might be something
wrong with being addicted to like meth
or some [ __ ] yeah the entire philosophy
of
making weed illegal because it's a
gateway drug that's a fallacy like yeah
exactly so like
yes like yeah if you're comparing him to
like that gateway fallacy it's like
there's a lot of people that radicalize
that don't listen to jordan peterson and
there are certain people that radicalize
that do listen to jordan peterson so i i
guess what i would
ask uh tenehesi coates
is uh do you feel the same way about
islam yeah some people get radicalized
listening to tony codes that's what it
i was trying to think what's the extreme
left version yeah i would say like
do you feel like islam is the same thing
as jordan peterson where a certain
small very small percentage of people by
the way happy ramadan
uh a very small percentage of people
that that are muslim will
lead a life of a muslim extremist right
and islam will i guess
bring them there but it's not really
islam it's like that person again
needing to fill a void or these
nefarious characters that are in their
life pushing them in that wrong
direction
do you place blame on islam for that
tanahisi coats because there's like a
philosophy that's that is potentially
being the weed
the gateway drug to that extremism yeah
i mean
or do you go those are completely
separate things and
islam is not responsible for that
extremism those extremists are
responsible for the extremism and
they're
using yeah using that drug what do you
think but
one thing is like if he was outwardly
calling
uh the red skull character jordan
peterson
he's just taking a few of his
philosophies that could be used to maybe
yeah but isn't that the way you would do
it you can't
say yeah but it's still that's like
actual slander i think you get sued but
it's a fictional character and like we
just said they're
weed can be a gateway drug so if you're
using some of his philosophies that
could be a gabriel oh oh it's like it's
definitely [ __ ] the way he's going
about it
yeah but it's still it's like it's it's
[ __ ] like really it's just
just call him jordan peterson it's just
not creative really yeah
that's really the big thing it's like oh
okay you're trying to make this uh
evil villain be more like bad and you're
just copying some bars from somebody
else also you're making the evil villain
the gateway
like it should be the evil thing not the
gateway yeah whoever is the forest
right the the evil villains always have
like a practice like they always have
philosophy
yeah do you think it was a sub tweet
that's kind of the way i looked at it
right i mean what's up yeah what up what
are the other things
i mean i'm just looking at it so this is
an excerpt from the comic apparently
where basically they're having a
conversation and this is something
captain america says he says
it's the same for all of them they're
look they're men weak looking for
purpose i found the flag
you found the badge and then they found
the skull is the next comic and he says
he tells them what they've always wanted
to hear and that they're secretly great
and that their the world is against them
and then if they're truly men they'll
fight back and bingo that's their
purpose that's what they'll live for and
that's what
they'll die for is what jordan peterson
tweeted
regarding the comic so like that was the
comic strip and then he basically
tweeted and said do i really live in a
universe where tony zucco's
is writing a a parody of my philosophy
to be red school
so i was like and then in the comic it's
like ten rules for life chaos and order
the
strap yeah yeah very specific like
directed
you know chaos and order like these big
themes that
that peterson talks about i think one
book was about chaos once that's so
annoying
so now what jordan peterson needs to do
is have his version of black panther
and just that's what he's got to do
and just take some of his bars put it as
the [ __ ] villain there you go
because at the end of the day is a
fictional character he's gonna write the
next black panther that's hilarious
funny jordan peterson will write a way
better killmonger than
wait time easy coats would yeah and if
killmonger finna take over
i want jordan peterson writing that one
yo i haven't read the comic maybe the
comic book slaps and jordan peterson got
to eat this
that's what i'm saying like if the comic
book slaps that excerpt did not slap
i'll tell you that that was a little
boring yeah it just seemed on both of
their parts
jordan got better bars bro i'll take the
hot [ __ ] think of a song or something
yeah i don't know it just seemed kind of
cheap like it's a poem what was he doing
that poem oh my god that's like come on
dude it's like it seems kind of cheap
that you're gonna make a comic
and like you're not gonna challenge his
ideas in like a direct way maybe he has
maybe i haven't seen it yeah brandon i'm
also not privy to all of jordan
peterson's work so maybe he says stuff
that is
misinterpreted uh or maybe it is like
objectively wrong i don't know i haven't
i haven't read his books but like at the
same time it seems cheap that you're
gonna create a piece of like
entertainment
the comic books are supposed to be
escapism yeah and then you're going to
insert
like a current political agenda it's
just annoying
and like there are people that read this
comic they love jordan peterson that
have like rekindled relationships with
their fathers
because of what jordan peterson wrote
and they're reading this and they're
like really
yeah like captain america i'm trying to
read this comic and you're making the
bad guy this guy that changed my life
yeah yeah i mean like i think it's clear
that jordan peterson has done objective
good in the world
yeah there's bigger fish to fry right
aren't there worse people to go after
this is the guy this is the villain yeah
who's
hitler to you yeah like red skull is
hitler right it's supervillain hitler
essentially
yes so like who's the worst person
that is existing you just take them yeah
and you make them red skull right yes
not this guy who
you might find kind of annoying or
whatever you know what i mean like even
if you made like an evil cop
that was like trying to kill people it's
like yeah that's the [ __ ] up and there
are evil cops that are trying to kill
black people like
their intention is yeah and like it
would be i don't know in line with the
story and the character and all that
[ __ ]
but instead of made like this
philosophical like this philosophical
thing that
now that being said i haven't read the
whole
comic book that's true and i haven't
read all of jordan peterson's work it
could go
the comic book could go and if it goes
if it's entertaining it wins
and it's smart let me attach it to
somebody who has some influence
now people are talking about comments
the last time you talked about a comic
before this is the kid cuddy dress of
comic books
yeah this is yeah it's smart well
[ __ ] done
you go after somebody who has a huge
social presence
you know that people on social media are
going to react
to it it's going to blow this [ __ ]
comic book out of
i mean jordan peterson is reacting to it
he's putting out merch based on it
he's like leaning all the way in he's
like putting out red skull merch
that's smart yeah i mean it's smart to
play into the comedy of it but who are
you really helping you're helping a guy
yeah who trashed you and said you're
hitler
but maybe he's helping himself and yeah
you're making money i'm curious to know
what time he see coates is responsible
because i've listened to a lot of his
stuff and i actually read tonight's book
you know
it didn't seem like crazy radical yeah i
mean yeah he doesn't seem like unhinged
no he just seems like the activist is
looking for
black success in america yeah and a
sharp guy
obviously good writer but um he has a
political agenda which is totally fine
nobody pushes back against that
but there's another it's like it's it's
tricky when you just call your
opposition hitler
yeah you know it seems a little easy to
just go to the jump to the hill yeah
you